While general purpose computing
is all the rage these days,
let's not forget about a
massive area of computing--
single purpose machines.
From point of sale devices to
vending machines and reception
kiosks to in-flight
entertainment,
computers that are produced
to serve a single purpose
are everywhere.
Often, these deployments
require a highly customized OS,
but now Android packs enough
of a punch for bespoke app
developers and enough control
for device administrators
to meet all these
needs out of the box.
I'm Rich Hyndman,
and I'm going to let
you know how to cater
for single-use devices
when writing your
apps and how they
can be easily provisioned and
managed using Android for Work.
With a new focus on
corporate-owned, single-use
devices, one or more
apps gets installed
when the device is initialized,
and it can be locked down
into Single App Mode.
That means things like the
home button and touch switch
are gone.
There are also enhanced
controls around the status
bar, notifications, incoming
calls, and quick settings
menus.
And of course, at reboot, it
will launch you right back
into your chosen application.
Because updates on these
devices can be problematic,
we've added APIs to give
IT admins the ability
to accept them remotely.
Admins can set an OTA
policy for a device
and use these APIs
to control them.
Remotely accepting OTAs,
scheduling maintenance windows,
or even postponing them
to give them a chance
to verify app compatibility.
Like all Android
for Work features,
COSU was designed to be
supported and managed
by your enterprise
mobility management vendor.
Once the supporting
EMM is configured,
provisioning your COSU device
is as simple as an NFC bump,
and you've got your own
interactive building map
or hotel check-in session.
As a developer,
there are a couple
of things to consider
when building
for single-use machines.
Firstly, the power
state of the device.
Many applications of COSU
devices will be plugged in
and require the screen to
be kept on the whole time.
There is a device policy
for it, but it's also worth
ensuring it's in
your application,
or at least make
it configurable,
as you might end up in
a multi-app COSU system.
The best way to do this is use
the Window Manager flag Keep
Screen On in your activity.
There's also the Keep
Screen On parameter you
can use in your XML layouts.
Your app should also
be self-contained.
Avoid things like the send
intent for single use apps.
Your app should work on
its own without the need
for interactions with
other applications,
as you want to be in full
control of the device
the whole time.
Probably goes without
saying, but it applies
to in-app purchases as well.
These devices won't have
access to the Play Store.
Finally, we also
recommend keeping your app
within one task.
Support for COSU
deployments will
mean you can now target a
huge range of new use cases
with your applications, and
we're really looking forward
to seeing the results.
When considering the
reach of Android for Work,
Enterprise Mobility
Management companies
make up a critical part
of the availability.
They integrate Android for
Work into their offerings
so that IT admins can manage the
devices in their organizations.
They install your apps
from Google Play for Work.
They apply security
policies, set up
corporate Wi-Fi networks,
application restrictions,
and they can even
set up single sign-on
by remotely installing
certificates.
We're constantly updating
the APIs available to EMMs
to give them more flexibility
in their offerings.
For more information on
integrating Android for Work
into your enterprise
management product,
you can contact us through
the Partnerships form
at google.com/work/android.
To simplify the testing
of your enterprise apps,
we've released and open-sourced
a new device policy
client called Test-DPC.
When developing
functionality for enterprise,
you could use
Test-DPC to simulate
the majority of features
of Android for Work.
The applets you set up are work
profile, apply device policies,
and set app and
intent restrictions.
You can even set
up COSU devices.
You can find the app
in our Github repo
at github.com/googlesamples.
It's ready for you to
incorporate into your testing
workflow.
These new updates
could revolutionize
single-use devices whilst
keeping IT admins happy.
For more developer
information, you can check out
developer.android.com/work,
whilst I go look up so more
acronyms.
So for now, it's TTFN for
BYOD whilst your apps go COSU.
[MUSIC PLAYING]